Kicking off the Halloween weekend, right,
we took our big kids on a Old South carriage tour.
Ghost tour of Charleston. Believe it or not,
me and my husband have never done this,
and this was the perfect opportunity
and such a fun way to start off our Halloween weekend.
Tour was about 40 minutes,
and we took our big kids, who are 8 and 9.
And honestly, it was perfect for kids.
Telling all of the creepy ghost stories
from some of Charleston's most historic buildings.
It was also just a beautiful way to see Charleston all lit up at night.
The kids had such a great time,
and so did my husband and I.
I really do think this is going to be a new family tradition.
To start off every Halloween weekend. Happy Halloween.